resolvamos otro de estos entretenidos
problemas de edad nos dicen
wendy tiene cuatro veces la edad de
bernardo hace doce años wendy tenía
siete veces la edad de bernardo qué edad
tiene bernardo actualmente una vez más
es una buena idea que primero intente
resolver esto por tu cuenta y después lo
trabajemos juntos
ahora cuál es la incógnita aquí bueno la
incógnita kim es la edad actual de
bernardo así que definamos una variable
igual a esto podemos usar equis o ye
pero como bernardo empieza con b usemos
b para bernardo
entonces sea p la edad actual de
bernardo la edad que tiene bernardo
actualmente veamos cómo se relaciona
toda esta información con la edad actual
de bernardo y con esto podemos construir
alguna ecuación y encontrar la respuesta
en esta ocasión lo haremos un poco más
estructurado de hecho podríamos haber
resuelto muchos de los problemas en los
que hemos estado trabajando de esta
manera vamos a pensar en bernardo y
también vamos a pensar en wendy que
trabajaremos en color azul ahora hay dos
puntos en el tiempo de los que estamos
hablando estamos hablando de hoy de lo
que pasa actualmente y también estamos
hablando de lo que pasó hace 12 años
así que por aquí vamos a escribir lo que
ocurre actualmente esta será la columna
de lo que ocurre actualmente y esta otra
será la columna de lo que ocurrió hace
12 años
veamos qué información podemos obtener
cuál es la edad de bernardo actualmente
bueno la hemos definido con la variable
be esa es la incógnita es lo que
queremos encontrar así que vamos a
escribirlo esta edad es ve ahora cuál es
la edad de bernardo hace 12 años y sería
conveniente que la expresamos en
términos de b bueno si tiene pe años
ahora hace 12 años tenía de menos 12
vamos bien ahora am cuál es la edad
actual de wendy bueno la primera oración
nos da esta información
wendy tiene cuatro veces la edad de
bernardo y podemos suponer que esto pasa
actualmente tiene cuatro veces la edad
de bernardo si la edad de bernardo
la edad de wendy va a ser 4 ver ahora
qué edad tenía buen día hace 12 años
bueno si ahora tiene 4 años hace 12 años
tenía 4 ve - 12 hace 12 años tenía 4 ve
- 12 esto es interesante pero todavía no
hemos utilizado la segunda oración hace
12 años wendy esta es la edad de buendía
hace 12 años hace 12 años wendy tenía 7
veces la edad de bernardo hace 12 años
este valor es siete veces este otro
valor
otra forma de pensarlo es que si tomamos
este valor y lo multiplicamos por 7
obtenemos este otro valor hace 12 años
la edad de bernardo era un séptimo de la
edad de wendy o la edad de winding era 7
veces la edad de bernardo
así que vamos a escribir esta idea como
una ecuación entonces podemos escribir
que 7 veces esto 7 veces la edad de
bernardo hace 12 años 7 por b menos 12
será igual a la edad de wendy hace 12
años será igual a 4 menos 12 y parece
que hemos hecho la parte difícil hemos
construido esta ecuación ahora podemos
usar nuestras herramientas algebraicas y
resolver para ver así que hagámoslo lo
primero que vamos a querer hacer es
distribuir el 7 es decir 7 por b y 7 por
menos 12 nos quedará 7 b menos 7 por 12
veamos eso es 84 7pm 84 es igual a 4 b
menos 12 esta expresión en el lado
izquierdo es literalmente 7 veces la
edad de bernardo hace 12 años
ahora qué podemos hacer para obtener ve
bueno podemos restar cuatro de ambos
lados vamos a hacerlo estos se cancelan
en el lado derecho y nos queda menos 12
mientras que en el lado izquierdo 7 b
menos 4 b nos da 3 b y también tenemos
menos 84 ahora queremos quitar este
menos 84 en el lado izquierdo así que
sumemos 84 de ambos lados en el lado
izquierdo nos quedaremos sólo con 3 b
mientras que en el lado derecho tenemos
menos 12 más 84 84 menos 12 que es 72 si
queremos resolver para ven vamos a
dividir entre 3 ambos lados de la
ecuación y obtenemos que b es igual y
aquí viene un redoble de tambor a 72
entre 3 tal vez seamos capaces de
hacerlo en nuestras mentes es 24 y
también podemos realizar esta división
en un papel de ser necesario es más
rápidamente vamos a hacerlo 72 entre 3
bueno 3 cabe dos veces en 73 por 12 6
761 bajamos el 2 y 3 cabe en 12 4 veces
entonces ven es igual a 24 si regresamos
a la pregunta qué edad tiene bernardo
actualmente la respuesta es 24 años pero
verifiquemos que en realidad sea la
respuesta correcta
nos dicen que wendy tiene cuatro veces
la edad de bernardo cuál es la edad
actual de wendy bueno cuatro veces 24 es
96 años entonces deberíamos de llamarla
doña wendy tiene
y seis años puede ser la abuela o la
bisabuela de bernardo y por otra parte
nos dicen que hace doce años wendy bueno
la edad de wendy era 84 años aquí son 84
años hace 12 años wendy tenía siete
veces la edad de bernardo bueno hace
doce años
bernardo tenía am y ahora tiene 24 hace
12 años tenía 12 años y en efecto 84 es
7 veces 12 así que todo funciona
correctamente